What’s the word, son? This week on Thug Notes we gettin regicidal with Macbeth by William Shakespeare.
After making a bitch out of their enemies, the king’s fresh generals, Macbeth and Banquo,
hit up three witches who start
laying down some cold prophecy.
Dem witches say one day Macbeth
gonna rock the crown as king,
and Banquo’s blood also gonna be
rollin on royals dubs one day.
Macbeth all geeked up bout bein big baller, but his woman, Lady Macbeth, be all like,
“Why you wastin time play boy?
You best get off yo lazy white ass and take dat sh*t.”
So Lady MacB convinces Macbeezy to shank King Duncan while he catchin some Z’s,
and lay the blame on his two chamberlains while they passed out from sippin too much drank.
Macbeth straight trippin after doin the deed,
so his woman steps up and puts the
bloody knife on the chamberlains as evidence.
When some fool Macduff finds
the king’s dead body,
MacBeth mercs dem Chamberlains
so they can’t dodge the heat.
All paranoid that somebody gonna ice them too, Duncan’s sons Malcom and Donalbain roll outta town.
With them punks outta the way,
Macbeth becomes the king.
Since the witches dun said Banquo’s
blood gonna be kings one day,
Macbeth starts buggin and sends a couple hoods to gat Banquo and his boy Fleance.
Banquo gets wrecked, but
Fleance ducks these fools.
Later, Macbeth hollas at the three
witches, who lay down some new prophecy.
First, an armored head tell him he
best watch his boy Macduff.
Then, a bloody child tell him that
nobody born of a woman can touch him.
Last, a crowned child holding a tree tells him he solid til Great Birnam trees roll up to the castle.
Word comes that Macduff dun roll out to England, so Macbeth gets ice cold and kills his whole family! Damn!
Later Macbeth learns that his woman done iced herself cuz she couldn’t get that blood off her hands.
At first, Macbeth ain’t sweatin the fact that Malcom’s returned and got a swole army creepin up to the castle.
But then he realizes the shields the army are using are from the same wood the witches warned him about.
Oh f**k. Since Macduff heard that his
family and castle got smoked,
he wanna go toe to toe with Macbeth.
On the battlefield, Macbeth says,
“Macduff, get off deez nuts. You were born of a woman. Can’t touch this!”
Turns out, Macduff’s mama had a
C-section when he was born,
so Macduff wipes dat nasty smile off
his mug and beheads this fool.
Then Malcom takes back his throne,
and Scotland got one less tyrant.
This play right here is a classical tragedy about a once righteous brutha who balls till he falls.
And it’s an unchecked ambition and lust for power that makes him his own antagonist.
But is Macbeth really the only one to blame for havin such a boot-leg fate?
Cuz on the real, it was Lady Macbeth who put a fire under his ass to merc the king.
And you could even blame the witches for feedin his ambition and givin him a big ol head.
And Scottish society gotta ride the beef too.
Back then, the main rap was
“you ain’t got a pair unless you grab all the power you can, no matter who you gotta kill for it."
So if you wanna say Macbeth got served cuz of all the people he shanked,
you best recognize he was gettin mad props for butcherin his enemies at the beginning of the play.
In fact, some literary thugz say that
Macbeth ain’t to blame at all,
but that fate slingin him around like a puppet,
making him act like a serious fool.
Just listen to how he talk bout life after his woman dies:
Cuz if Macbeth ain’t got no choice,
then all this sh*t is straight meaningless.
Since fate, society, and Macbeth’s big-ass head layin more pressure on him than he can handle,
Shakespeare droppin images of clothes that don’t fit good to show how this playa livin way outta his depth.
Hey, y’all know how to make a playa feel loved, man.
So spread the love and tell yo friends!
Peace!